[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sur la troisième
[Applaudissements]
le tour volley-ball c'est un des plus
beaux clubs de France et c'est aussi un
des palmes Marais c'est plus important
tout ce sport confondu donc le tour
volley-ball rende peu à peu dans le
patrimoine du sport français
ça fait 20 ans qu'on est au niveau mais
on a mis du temps on a mis du temps pour
arriver économiquement on a mis du temps
pour séduire on a mis du temps pour
convaincre et dans le sport de haut
niveau beaucoup de clubs arrêtent parce
qu'ils sont pressés et nous on n'a pas
été aussi pressé que ça c'est l'histoire
qui le dit mais il faut regarder
l'histoire pour le savoir
l'histoire justement elle est intimement
liée à la pire angulaire du TVB l'homme
de tous les titres Pascal Foussard
en 40 ans le club a tout connu les
montées le premier titre la Coupe de
France 2003
[Applaudissements]
le premier titre de champion de France
l'année suivante
[Applaudissements]
et même la Ligue des Champions en 2005
par un soir d'exaltation grec
Salonique avec 15000 personnes c'était
voilà on pensait pas la gagner mais on
avait aussi beaucoup d'ambitions cachées
parce qu'on avait quelques joueurs qui
étaient les meilleurs à leur poste du
monde et on avait réussi à créer un
groupe incroyable et on l'a gagné de
façon aussi incroyable mais on a
peut-être pour l'histoire du cloud dans
la peut-être gagné un peu trop tôt parce
que trois ans après on jouait le
maintien donc voilà ça va très vite dans
le sport de niveau
tout aura eu beaucoup de chance a eu la
chance de voir les la ville de Tours les
meilleures équipes du monde les
meilleurs joueurs du monde passé
qui aurait dit à 20 ans 30 ans que le
volley-ball serait le sport le plus
important quasiment entouraine personne
mais absolument personne moi j'ai joué
Grenon raisonner le vide ou beaucoup de
monde lorsqu'on est monté en Pro B et le
club s'est créé sur une dynamique de
public et après d'entreprise et après
qu'il est séduit le public et
l'entreprise ils ont séduit les
collectivités mais ça mille beaucoup de
temps malgré tout ce qu'on a fait malgré
public malgré malgré les résultats
malgré tout ça et le volley-ball est un
parent pauvre peut-être par moment du
sport faut le reconnaître malgré que en
Touraine on est les rois
et ça c'est dur
entraîneur manager directeur délégué
mais aussi patriarche et gardiens d'une
institution
après 40 ans à tous les postes après 40
ans de sacrifices et de loyauté
il sera temps pour Pascal Foussard de
quitter la salle mythique grenou non je
continue
non non j'arrête en juin 2024 c'est
prévu depuis trois ans et un moment
donné le tour volley-ball a pas beaucoup
vécu sans parce qu'elle fout ça mais
vivre à santascal Foussard et c'est
normal ça fait partie de la vie et nul
et ni remplaçable
demain nous reviendrons sur cette saison
exceptionnelle
ponctuée par un nouveau doublé coupe
championnat